the eight-time russian champion peter
spidler a friend of the club of course
came in at the last minute to replace a
good friend of his as you were coming
here to do commentary peter yesterday
before we talk about today's draws
yesterday must have been a heartbreak
game yeah that wasn't great
because i think in terms of quality of
play i until i played 98 i feel like it
was one of the better
games i've played in a while i felt like
i found some decent decisions i
understand computer criticizes some
small things but
there were there were some things there
that i think i've uh i've handled well
and yeah
one move away from uh you know
brain glitches are
something i'm kind of used to by this
point but uh
it's very unfortunate when like your one
real glitch per game just loses you the
game instantly like there's no coming
back you go 98 you resign
and uh
yeah that wasn't very enjoyable but
yeah i got i got some of it back today
because today was
i think i played wars today then i
played yesterday
uh this move bishop a3 shocked us all
yeah i couldn't really figure out what
i'm supposed to do and uh that's also or
you know that's already kind of a
you know a severe indictment in itself
because it's a theoretical position but
i uh
yeah i wasn't entirely sure what uh
what to play for and obviously this was
connected with uh with a miscalculation
uh because i kind of underestimated how
playable knight takes e3 is
that's not to say that you know other
moves are bad for uh for black um in uh
yeah 95 i saw but like i i don't like it
i don't think it's particularly great i
i kind of considered similar things and
uh
did not uh
yeah i think basically i was like half a
step away from actually solving this
position because i considered bishop g5
but bishop chief no i mean with white
and bishop g5 with white is not that
great because it allows knight f4 in all
these positions like take takes knight
of four is already quite unpleasant and
yeah i just like knight
seemed uh
you know
vague vague
enough that i didn't really didn't
really consider it properly i i assume
black is still like even bishop g5s g556
followed by bishop p6 i probably take
black in the position to be honest but
uh yeah it's better than what i played
but what i played was you know it's uh
it's very principled it just doesn't
work
uh because like if 92 if 92 actually
works out tactically uh i i quite like
my i quite like my idea uh but yeah
there is this there's also you know now
that i'm finally here and i can do you
know my actual job you know
which is talk about chess yeah uh
instead of knight takes e3 b5 was
incredibly dangerous
i was actually you know
i i wouldn't say this is stronger but
it's i think it more or less forces me
to take on d5
and i was trying to calculate this
position queen d5 i think i have to play
c4
i don't think i have time to play 94 bhp
seven so i have to play c4 and now queen
d3
uh rookie three queen g6 specifically
queen g6 i think she takes b5 knight e7
and it's very possible i'm getting
specifically 97 yeah with knight g5
knight f5 ideas
and what i
was calculating in like sheer panic was
the position of the knight takes e5
and
first of all even taking a bishop b7 is
strong but the problem is queen of queen
of five here yeah i mean here i think i
found a way to save the game with like
queen specifically knight f3 i think
doesn't lose
i've like i'm not really convinced about
anything i you know think about chess
these days but this i thought
might be yeah the [ __ ] 23 is horrible
but i have a pawn up and you know i will
be able maybe to trade some pieces but
instead of the twin five
and whenever you know wherever i put my
knight from g2 like c2 or c4 or f3
doesn't matter uh black just goes bishop
b7
and now you know 95 knight f4 rkd8
knight g6 all these things
and i only have one pawn to show for it
you know like if i were three up here
maybe i'd be maybe i'd be you know
somewhat optimistic but i'm only one up
here yeah nice coordination yeah it
looked it looked like i'm kind of
borderline lost here so i was panicking
trying to figure out how to improve on
this and then shaq took on c3 and i
realized you know it's also possible to
be quite
you know straightforward
and i think what i did is more or less
strictly forced i don't think i can
improve
up until 26 king h8 and yeah and uh as
another participant of this tournament
famously wrote
about pawns moving backwards you know if
that thing was on b3 instead of b5
it might be much better actually
but it's not
uh
and uh yeah
i don't know you're struggling yeah i
don't know if the sun game is like
mathematically lost or not but
uh i was actually much more this felt to
me like as usual rook endings kind of
give you chances i was instead of b6
i was
i thought a5 is probably winning
with the idea of playing a4 and
stabilizing the knight on b4 on b5
meaning that i probably have to play a4
knight c3 rook c7 knight a4
and uh i've progressed black's game plan
tremendously i can play knight b3 here
and it gets a little bit tricky because
like every single pawn on the queen side
is currently hanging considering the
background problems
but it felt to me that
you know with precise play this has to
be bad yeah b6 and i was planning to
play
uh
some kind of a passing move here i don't
know f4 or whatever
start pushing something forward and hope
that this is somehow not lost but right
uh it looked really really scary to me
and i couldn't see how to avoid it
because like if i allow the pawn to get
to a4 i will never shift the knight from
b5 and
and then
i i don't really know how to
uh you know how to even press
and eventually bad things will start
happening on on the queen side with four
against two i think you nailed it
beautifully well there yeah so
yeah i think i think that was probably
cleaner but i think shah underestimated
just how tricky that rook ending was
that we got in the game i assume it's
winning somehow but i also think it's
not trivial
uh he was saying that maybe rook d8
instead of rook f8 maybe rook g8 king c2
rookie 8 might be winning
but you already have to start you know
giving up your entire queen side here to
you know collect my entire king side and
you know we might be off to some sort of
races and i might hold the engine gives
you as drawing this position as well
okay yeah so
as usual uh you know i always assess
these positions like i i basically take
a look at the score sheet figure out
which side i'm playing and that side and
that side does as poorly as is possible
to do in the position right so like if i
were black it would be a draw and uh
since i was white i assumed i will lose
it somehow
but
i wasn't you know going to just resign
i'm still going to try to make the best
moves and you know
eventually that that turned out to be
okay good that you drew that game we're
going to put you to work as a
commentator because a lot of excitement
is going on right now so let's all go to
work as fabiano caruana has crawled all
the way back was down a pawn but lanier
in time pressure played a couple of soft
moves he did get the knight to b7 but
bulma rook down on d1 rook to e1 trying
to defend takes takes and queen e4 yeah
we have very differing
definitions of excitement
[Laughter]
i just want to
[Laughter]
put an eye on the clock
here but now they've liquidated down
and it looks like fabi has saved the
game where he looked like he was in real
trouble earlier guys well he was down a
pawn yeah yeah
i want to say i have i don't know how
much you were speaking about this in the
studio but i want to say a6 bishop a5
when lanier played a6 i thought okay the
only reason you would ever play a6 is to
play bishop by five but there's no way
this can work
and apparently it does and it's just so
impressive to me that he even like
considered this because it looks like
you're moving all of your pieces away
from the center and all of black's
pieces go all the way back
25-ish yeah right here
yeah because you will have to take with
the knight as well leaving your leaving
your king side sort of not entirely
unprotected but then i realized just how
much work the move knight b7 does in
this position like it does so much heavy
lifting because otherwise like after
something like 94 94 rook d4 there would
be so many threats on the king side but
the knight just
plugs all of this completely
you're getting to be seven and then the
bishop on f1 is perfectly uh perfectly
good enough to hold yeah i was i was
incredibly impressed by uh by linear
going for this because
maybe it's not the best but it's just an
idea that
i was fantastic i mean yeah i personally
i personally don't know if i would have
seen uh considering you know that all
the play is going on in the center and
on the king side and you make two moves
on the on the opposite side of the board
moving things uh far far away from where
seemingly all the action is peter from
the comment you just made
you it seems obvious that you're keeping
close eye on the other games in progress
and even calculating
as you've just
done is is that common for you to walk
around i always i always do that i've
always done that and uh
yeah it's uh
it's probably better not to but i can't
i can't really how do you stay fresh for
your game when you're calculating uh
five games at once you've seen how i
play here i mean maybe maybe it's time
to actually like blink or blinker
yourself physically somehow you know
but uh yeah uh never happened before it
probably will never happen
well young jeffrey's also defending his
position peter we're going to thank you
for joining us and get your energy and
good luck in the rest of your games
thank you thank you for joining us peter